like Evo's Shores are always busy as
people from around Gomer gather their
daily water supplies for some this is
the only water they can find for
drinking and washing and keeping cleans
now even more important in this densely
populated city after the first cases of
the Ebola virus were confirmed here last
month water stands have been set up
outside public buildings and at the busy
border crossing with Rwanda because of
the Ebola epidemic we have to wash our
hands all the time but the problem is
water isn't easy to find here in Goma
every day Ellis can work eq's for hours
at public taps like many in the
Democratic Republic of Congo she doesn't
have running water at home there are
four of us at home every morning I wake
up at 6 in order to get to the fountain
because I live a bit far from here it
takes about five hours to get access to
the tap we suffer a lot because we need
at least five cans per household the
Ebola virus begins with a fever and
vomiting and often leads to massive
internal bleeding and death it spread
through direct contact with body fluid
so good hygiene vital even the dead and
their coffins are sanitized before being
buried Ebola while it's not caused
through water having access to water is
really important for prevention efforts
ensuring that there's good hygiene
practices hand-washing is another main
means of prevention and so while it
water is not the cause it's still really
important for helping to curb this
epidemic nearly 2,000 people have been
killed so far and what's the longest and
deadliest outbreak in the country's
history there's been no new cases
reported and gomer this month but many
in the city still fear how they'll be
able to avoid the disease if they don't
have enough water to wash their hands
Alexei O'Brien al-jazeera